Das ist wirklich eine sensationelle Entdeckung,
die ein chinesisch-australisches Forschungsteam
da gemacht hat.
Denn obwohl die Milchstraße ja quasi unsere
kosmische Heimat ist, wissen wir längst noch
nicht alles über sie.
Doch durch die Positions-Bestimmung von hunderten
speziellen Sternen haben Fachleute jetzt eine
dreidimensionale Karte der Milchstraße erstellt.
Und die enthüllt eine wirklich spannende
Besonderheit unserer Galaxie!
Clixoom Science & Fiction, hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Sciencevideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Dieses Thema ist wirklich besonders spektakulär
- und es kommt von Euch, aus dem Clixoom Discord-Server
- vielen Dank dafür!
Konkret geht es um die Milchstraße, von der
Forschungsteams weltweit bisher angenommen
hatten, dass sie relativ flach ist, bis auf
die Ausbuchtung in der Mitte.
Da hatten wir ja drüber berichtet.
Sie stammt von der Kollsion mit einer anderen
Galaxie, die jetzt Teil unserer Milchstraße
ist.
Und schließlich erinnern auch andere Spiralgalaxien
wie Andromeda beispielsweise an eine Scheibe.
Und das ist ganz easy durch ein Teleskop zu
sehen.
Anders dagegen bei der Milchstraße.
Sie ist eine Besonderheit und Ihre Form ist
nicht so einfach zu bestimmen.
Das liegt ganz einfach an unserer Position
- schließlich ist die Erde ein Teil von ihr
und befindet sich mitten in dieser Sternenansammlung.
Die Milchstraße als Ganzes zu sehen macht
das unmöglich.
Doch schon seit einiger Zeit gibt es Hinweise
darauf, dass die Milchstraße vor allem in
ihrem äußeren Bereich gar nicht so flach
sein könnte, wie die Fachleute es bisher
angenommen hatten.
Doch wie soll man das herausbekommen?
Ein internationales Forschungsteam bediente
sich jetzt eines Tricks und bestimmte zunächst
die genauen Positionen von 1339 speziellen
Sternen.
Konkret ging es dabei um junge, massereiche
Sterne, die zur Gruppe der Cepheiden (Aussprache:
Ke-feh-iden) gehören.
Das Besondere an diesen sogenannten “kosmischen
Meilensteinen”: Sie leuchten bis zu 100.000
Mal heller als unsere Sonne.
Die Helligkeit dieser Sterne, die die Fachleute
als Positionsanzeiger nutzen, unterliegt einem
Schwankungs-Rhythmus.
Dabei hängt die Länge seines Taktes von
der Leuchtkraft des jeweiligen Sterns ab.
Somit kann nicht nur relativ easy die absolute
Helligkeit des Cepheiden-Sterns bestimmt werden,
sondern auch seine Entfernung zur Erde.
Auch die exakten Position am Himmel ist bekannt
und somit gelang es den Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler dann, eine dreidimensionale
Karte zu erstellen.
Und diese lüftet das bislang verborgene Geheimnis:
Bei der Milchstraße handelt es sich um eine
ganz besondere Spiralgalaxie.
Sie ist alles andere als eben, sondern deutlich
verformt.
Quasi tatsächlich krumm und schief.
Auch, wenn die Sternen- und Gasscheibe der
Milchstraße relativ deckungsgleich sind,
zeigt die 3D-Karte, dass beide auffällig
verbogen sind.
Dabei weichen die äußeren Regionen unserer
Milchstraße von der Hauptebene der Sternscheibe
auf der einen Seite nach oben und auf der
anderen Seite nach unten bogenförmig ab.
Schaut man sich die Milchstraße in diesem
Modell von der Seite an, ist sie leicht S-förmig.
Dazu der australische Forscher Richard de
Grijs: “In den äußeren Regionen der Galaxie
haben wir zudem festgestellt, dass die s-förmige
Sternenscheibe in einem zunehmend verbogenen
Spiralmuster verformt ist.”
Die Form unserer Milchstraße ist damit ziemlich
selten, allerdings nicht einzigartig.
Denn solch eine verzogene und verdrehte Spirale
war auch schon bei anderen Galaxien beobachtet
worden.
Und genau diese Beobachtungen liefern auch
Hinweise auf die Ursache der Verformung.
Nach Ansicht des Forschungsteams könnte sie
durch ein Drehmoment der rotierenden massereichen
inneren Sternenscheibe der Milchstraße begründet
sein.
Fest steht jedenfalls: Die Erkenntnisse zur
Form der Milchstraße könnten die Grundlage
legen, die Geschichte der Milchstraße weiter
zu entschlüsseln.
Zudem könnte dieses Forschungsergebnis auch
bei weiteren ungeklärten Fragestellungen
helfen.
Dazu Licai Deng, einer der beteiligten Forscher:
“Diese Ergebnisse liefern uns eine neue
Kartengrundlage für die Erforschung der stellaren
Bewegungen in der Galaxie.”
Denn klar ist: Mit einer Vorstellung davon,
wie die Milchstraße aussieht, ist es sehr
viel einfacher, Entfernungen von der Sonne
in die Außenbereiche der Galaxie zu bestimmen.
Danke auf jeden Fall für diesen spektakulären
Themenvorschlag zum Discordserver kommt ihr
über unseren WhatsApp-Newsletter.
In der Begrüßungsnachricht ist der Link.
Dafür hier draufklicken!
Ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran!